таврійський національний університет
імені Вернадського їжі на кримську вище
початковий заклад я до ipo нову свою
роботу у каїві початок початковому уроку
свитку і тю примітка міністерство
усвяти
целлер вдало адреси університету
фізичний поганий травня
checking одним тому виковувати обидва віскі
у ректора владимир казарин загнали
сумнівався, що в дастер usb від шоти
навчальний рик лінз колінами тіла літав
б у другому і мінус цієї а б ви робили
приймеш рішення для дала
lc перший успіх - ми думав ще зустрину
ми тут нехай і при лікуванні відсік для ми
на великому подарунок ще хочу від села
головного болю не буде нас не буде
вулиця якорі замість університету ви
робить відчувати ринок чайні корпус і
джен та 10 факультету гуманітарного на
премку
на вч а там від вся моя жирі 700
студентів b6 з криму cvn за
нині їжі на його крики чоловіки
прийнятої дітей за купава на муки острова
в російській та документами для багатьох
не можна давати огс криму не моєму
слабкості надходить і в українську вище
там уже вжито український атестат
тут можна з російською це стало
поставити українською логічного та мало
рвучкі університету апаратура ніші
під час після анексії
вона частина візерунка рік чи півтора
студентка філологія алісу почалася out
in you done exe путін правило сеульський
національний університет топпер знав
повернулася а у св у таврійського
вікон та травня свого рота рідкі у студентів
розстріляють гурти рідких інших вийшов
протеолізу згодна жито утида звільнені
комфорт деяким на ті захист від 50 гр
війна місити і на те в тесті на
контракті головне у своїх кримських ви
скарбу чого я знаю че знаєш чоловікові
досягнуто за де до університету я
зможе займатися мережі та науку велику
звучу
викладок ebay she's я як прибув з
крыму як студенти тих же ти муть varta
рідко хни вусища втрило місця менше
того дістань його в новизна кращий
прийняла їх на роботу після довгий був
наріжте після відривав витягувати я
намастить вранці це селективного док шкоди
адресою департаменту фінанси у мінус вигляд
вже і наріжте штатний розкладки
дозволяю викладав в офіційному
статус на чат з туди йти до
студентам на каспар створи немає видав та
на посадку 2015 у -3 ти поважаєш
трохи а зараз розробляємо вузли ви
обидва університет по нову в свою
діяльність
фінансування тонн закладу на удар
бюджеті на нас тут дерек